try this
hello my name is Rosie and I first you
just want to say a huge thank you to you
all because I am no expert you really
are and I've learned more today than I
could ever hope to in months of sitting
in the middle east and skyping you all
and hoping that you'll be there and and
trying to learn how to better talk about
this subject so we've been spending the
last my group which is media danton or
so another production company in the UK
called anagram have been spending the
last two years looking at this subject
desperate to try and find a way in that
we think would engage the public
properly because so far I think the
public is although aware of the subject
a little bit more about it all and
that's what we hope to change so I've
been listening a lot to today and what's
been quite encouraging for us is that I
think that all of the things that you
guys are asking for I think we are going
to answer in our project and I'd like to
present to you an idea that I'm hoping
some of you might want to be involved in
so a lot of you have talked today about
education and the need for education at
every level from four and five-year-olds
understanding not to put a push of ours
onto the floor and to local and regional
and global education about the value of
cultural heritage and we hope that our
project will engage at all levels and
fire via many different platforms that
we all use everyday in the social media
world you've also talked about the need
for greater legislation and we hope that
our project will be some sort of spark
towards the creation of a taboo around
this subject about this crime and
something similar to the way seatbelts
are now to not wear a seatbelt or to put
your child in a car seat is considered
absolutely horrific whereas in the 80s
it was kind of fine and in fact where I
live it's still kind of fine to not have
your child in a car seat and i have to
say very quiet most of the time and but
we hope that our project will lead to
creating something of a taboo around
this subject and i also think that
generally we're losing the media battle
when all of us sitting here we've not
watched a single Isis video today but
all of us can recall probably five six
seven of them in our minds and
images that they've dramatically put up
on the on the internet have been spread
widely and whereas we're battling with
with documentaries in long form a few
newspaper articles which admittedly are
excellent and brilliantly researched but
i can tell you today i've been tweeting
like man maniacally tweeting and I've
got quite a avid following on Twitter
and in fact the first tweet i hadn't
reply was from a member of Isis who said
actually we you know we are not going to
be defeated and I've only had about two
or three retweets which is totally not
normal for me so it shows to me that all
of my very my very engaged the very
engaged Twitter following that I have
all in the media and not that interested
even though what I think I've been
listening to is fascinating and yeah
like I said the ISIS videos we can all
think of even though we're not watching
them right now and what we hope to do is
through this engagement also we hope
lead to something of the whistle blowing
and that some of you have also called
for so we're going to be trying to hit
all of those notes in our project so our
overall aim is to engage a worldwide
multi-platform audience in your fight
against this crime and we hope that we
can be a conduit for your story and all
the things that you guys want to achieve
we're going to do that by by hopefully
finding a way to relate the objects that
you're all talking about or the visuals
that you're all talking about of of
giant things like Jenna in in Mali and
to relate that to people's own history
and own stories the history of objects
was the first way of understanding what
has is the only way to understand what
happened perhaps 6,000 years ago and and
we hope that people in today's world
where an internet of things as a buzz
word and can relate to that in a very
modern way through our project we're
going to enable them like I say here to
literally reach out and touch and feel
the subject in all its dimensions and
we're also going to give a people a
chance to tell their their own stories
how are we going to do that
we're going to first of all create an
online interactive website we've got
support from a number of people the New
York Times seems to be the front-runner
there and we're going to ask we're going
to go on a hunt and find five objects
that have been stolen that have also
been recovered and try and trace their
modern-day story how did they get there
what's the likely route that they took
will pick obvious places like eBay or a
Brussels antique shop or a somewhere in
Beirut places where these things are
often turning up so that we can tell a
more general story not a very specific
story about these these five objects
then we'll also try an attempt although
it's very difficult as you know to tell
the historical story of these objects
whether it be in film or in art so it's
got a current affairs and an art
dimension to it so far and we've been
very lucky in the in the course of our
inquiries somebody mentioned to us along
the way in one of the locations that we
work in the Middle East that they'd
found a box full of treasures frankly
and we went along to go and see them we
were bowled over by the feeling it gave
us to be something that you guys are
also used to I'm afraid but for me it's
not I've never experienced this before
but to be so close to this bird that was
so is so ancient and to feel and the
fragility of this object that's wrapped
in loo paper and kind of kept in a box
on a shelf and some of these I'm sure
some of you noticing immediately our
fakes and others are real and but for us
the the proximity of these amazing
things and the fragility of them like i
say made us feel like there was a better
way to engage the public in this subject
and then just merely documenting what's
what's been going on so then we go to
the next level of our our project so
we're also going to 3d model those five
objects that we've told the ancient and
modern stories of and make those 3d
models available online so
people can download them themselves and
host their own pop-up exhibitions around
the world or simply print one off for
their mum for Christmas I don't know
whether you know now but but you can
actually print porcelain and with a
glaze on it as well that's very specific
and I don't know quite how it works
because I'm not doing that part of the
project but it looks much more real than
you imagine and you can also print it
very crudely which has its own artistic
merits in some people's views and then
the third level of our story is on this
website we're going to encourage people
to upload their own stories and their
own objects now it might be something
which has a relationship with the Syrian
and Iraqi story that we're going to
start our project with and or it might
be something that has no particular
relationship to that so it may be for
instance that it's a doll and that made
its way to Kansas with a with a girl and
that becomes another object in a pop-up
exhibition or maybe somebody sitting at
home and they choose to 3d scan that
object with the three or four apps are
available on your phone for free to 3d
scan an object or just take a photo of
it tell its story and upload it onto the
site and that becomes your plunder it
could be it could be something
completely unrelated like a you know
this strange little animal are not quite
sure how to describe it a goat I guess
and which your your aunt gave you who
had some importance in your life it
could be a shopping if you were holding
an exhibition in a in a big hall of
these five objects your sixth object
could be for instance a shopping trolley
full of precious things that belong to a
[ __ ] and a thing that's precious and
has a story to tell that's what we're
looking for and this by the way this
project i'm just going to give a give
him a a bit of a plug is by a guy called
xia gothic these objects and he uploads
every day a new object he took a
thousand and one pictures of objects
from the sarajevo mass graves and he
uploads are different one each day some
he has stories for in sudden he doesn't
but i always found that a very engaging
thing to look at and we hope in this way
that this online website will grow and
grow and grow and it may be filled with
stolen syrian
rocky objects or it may just be filled
with odd little things that people think
are important in the world might want to
know about but they'll all be available
online for people to take an interest in
and so and then we're here mainly to
learn but we also need your help and
brainpower we're looking for those five
objects if you have one that you think
is interesting that that's been
discovered something that your Institute
knows about something that you've heard
about please can you come up to me after
this and help find us fine fine me or
I've got a producer sitting in the
audience here and who will who can talk
to you about that object and we're also
it's a work in development so for
instance I already spoke to somebody
earlier about possibly adding a
whistleblowing element you know if this
will encourage people to whistleblow and
can we add whistleblowing elements this
on the website and we're really open to
suggestions at this point and the last
thing it's a little bit awkward because
I know it's not easy but we're looking
for funding and we're right at the
beginning we've got a certain amount of
money but we need to make this happen we
believe it's important and we believe it
will work thank you very much